wie wird Geld geschaffen woher kommt es
wer profitiert davon und welchem Zweck
dient es was ist dein Geldsystem was ist
das Geld hinter dem Geldsystem
seit Jahrhunderten ist die Mechanik des
Geldsystems vor den neugierigen Blicken
der Bevölkerung verborgen geblieben doch
seine Auswirkungen sowohl auf nationaler
als auch auf internationaler Ebene sind
vielleicht unübertroffen
denn das Finanzsystem schafft die
Grundlage für internationale Dominanz
und nationale Kontrolle
heute da diese Grundlagen von Krisen
erschüttert werden ist ein offener und
ehrlicher Dialog über die Zukunft des
Geldsystems dringlicher denn je
diese Wirtschaftskrise ist wie ein
Krebsgeschwür wenn sie nur warten und
warten und denken dass dies von selbst
verschwinden wird genau wie ein
Krebsgeschwür wird es wachsen und es
wird irgendwann zu spät sein bereitet
euch vor im Moment ist keine Zeit für
Wunschdenken dass die Regierung die
Dinge schon Regeln wird der Regierungen
regieren nicht die Welt Goldman Sachs
regiert die Welt
wir stehen am Rande einer Katastrophe
ungeahnten Ausmaßes
in Konkurrenz zueinander stehen korrupte
und etablierte Interessen die in den
Korridoren der Macht lauern für die es
keine Gründe gibt ihre Privilegien
aufzugeben
hatte einen Reformplan für das
Gesundheitssystem nein hatte einen
Reformplan für die Polizei nein hatte
einen Plan um das Defizit zu reduzieren
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
versuchen Sie sich zu beruhigen und sich
wie ein Erwachsener zu benehmen falls es
Ihnen nicht möglich sein sollte dann
verlassen Sie die Räumlichkeiten raus
hier wir kommen auch ohne sie zurecht
das ist die Futterstelle der
Bankverbindungen
um 1700 zu einem echten zyklischen Thema
wurden als William Petterson die Bank of
England gründete
[Applaus]
dies ist ein unerträgliches Verhalten
sobald es die Öffentlichkeit betrifft
nein es ist nicht lustig
nur in ihrem Kopf ist es lustig es ist
überhaupt nicht lustig es ist eine
Schande
die einzige Lösung Revolution
das System ist von Natur aus instabil
aufgrund der internationalen
Machtverteilung zugunsten der dominanten
Parteien denn eigentlich geht es um wie
bekomme ich etwas umsonst
statistische Analysen haben gezeigt dass
die Währung eines Imperiums entwertet
wird wenn es sich seinem eigenen
Untergang nähert
es gibt keine Anleitung wie dieses ganze
System funktioniert ein Forscher der BBC
der in einem Dokumentarfilm von Robert
peston arbeitet ging zur Bank of England
und sagte können Sie mir einen Leitfaden
geben wie Geld geschaffen wird und sie
sagten dort nur nein
dieser Dokumentarfilm wird dieses sich
ständig verändernde System und die
Auswirkungen die es sowohl auf
nationaler als auch auf internationaler
Ebene hat untersuchen und erklären
[Musik]
nein die seven percent
wie entsteht Geld
Banknoten und Münzen
in China im Jahr 2010 lag die gesamte
britische Geldmenge bei 2,15 Billionen
Pfund 2,6 Prozent davon waren physisches
Bargeld
53,5 Milliarden der Rest 2,1 Billionen
oder 97,4 Prozent der gesamten Geldmenge
waren Geschäftsbank Geld
centralbanks werden durch die
Zentralbank geschaffen und wenn man
einen 10 Pfund Schein herstellt kann man
den an der Bank für ihre Geldautomaten
verkaufen und die Bank muss die 10 Pfund
zurückzahlen oder kaufen es wird kein
Zins auf das Geld erhoben dieses Geld
wird dann letztlich an das
Finanzministerium weitergeleitet es ist
eine Form der Beschaffung von Geldmittel
für die Regierung das nennt sich Senior
rich Profit den eine Regierung durch die
Ausgabe von Währungen erzielt die
Differenz zwischen dem Nennwert von
Banknoten und Münzen und ihren
Produktionskosten
Bank of England eine zehn pfund-note
herstellt kostet es etwa drei oder vier
Pants um diesen Schein tatsächlich zu
drucken sie verkaufen den Geldschein den
Geschäftsbanken zum Nominalwert von 10
Pfund der Profit der Unterschied
zwischen den Druckkosten und dem
Verkaufspreis von 10 Pfund geht direkt
an das Finanzministerium also jeglicher
Profit aus der Erschaffung von
physischem Geld Banknoten geht ans
Finanzministerium das reduziert die
Menge an Steuern die wir zahlen müssen
im Laufe der letzten 10 Jahre sind so
Einnahmen von 18 Milliarden Pfund
entstanden
1948 machten Banknoten und Münzen 17%
der gesamten Geldmenge aus dies war ein
Faktor der zur Fähigkeit der Regierung
bei trug den Wiederaufbau nach dem Krieg
zu finanzieren dazu gehörte auch die
Gründung des nationalen
Gesundheitswesens in nur 60 Jahren sind
Banknoten und Münzen auf weniger als
drei Prozent geschrumpft
vor
1844 wurden Banknoten von Privatbanken
geschaffen und die Regierung profitierte
nicht davon
vor der Industrialisierung gab es
mehrere Formen nebeneinander
existierenden Geldes und so ist der
Aufstieg des staatlich geförderten Fiat
Geld ist ein relativ neues
phänomenow los
in den 1840er Jahren gab es kein Gesetz
den Banken zu verbieten ihre eigenen
Banknoten zu erschaffen also haben sie
Papiergeld herausgegeben dass ihrem
Kontostand entsprach anstatt mit
schweren Metallmünzen zu bezahlen
erhielten sie ein Stück Papier auf dem
Stand wie viel sie auf der Bank haben
man konnte dann mit diesem Papier die
schweren Münzen bei der Bank abholen
im Laufe der Zeit war dieses Papiergeld
genauso gut wie Münzgeld die Leute
benutzten Papiergeld an statt zur Bank
zu gehen um das echte Geld abzuholen
sobald die Bank merkten dass ihr
Papiergeld die Hauptwährung in der
Wirtschaft geworden war erkannten sie
dass sie Gewinner erzeugen konnten wenn
sie mehr davon herstellten sie können
einfach neue Noten drucken sie verleihen
und dafür noch Zinsen verlangen und das
haben sie bis in die 1840er Jahre
gemacht bis sie es ein bisschen zu weit
getrieben haben das verursachte eine
Inflation und die stabilisierte die
Wirtschaft
1844 hat die konservative Regierung um
Robert Peel ein Gesetz erlassen dass den
Geschäftsbanken die Macht Geld zu
schaffen nahm und sie wieder dem Staat
übertrug seitdem wurde alles
digitalisiert was wir jetzt als Geld
verwenden sind digitale Zahlen die die
Geschäftsbanken aus dem Nichts
erschaffen
das Problem war dass sie in dieser
Gesetzgebung die Sichteinlagen nicht
berücksichtigt haben Einlagen einzelner
Kunden bei den Banken oder elektronische
Formen von Geld was Sichteinlagen heute
vorwiegend sind der Großteil des Geldes
in Umlauf heute ist elektronisches Geld
es sind Sichteinlagen die auf unseren
Konten liegen die Gesetzgebung muss mit
den Entwicklungen des elektronischen
Geldes Schritt halten und mit der Art
und Weise wie Banken funktionieren
wird wird als Sichteinlagen bezeichnet
dies ist ein buchhalterischer Begriff
den die Banken verwenden wenn sie
Kredite erstellen Banken folgen dem
gleichen Prozess wenn sie Kredite
vergeben alles Geld das auf Bankkonten
gehalten wird ist ein
buchhaltungseintrag
Geschäftsbank Geld
Realität ist jetzt dass das meiste Geld
weder Papier noch Münzen sind sondern
digital es sind nur Ziffern in einem
Computersystem es ist ihre Visa
Debitkarte es ist ihre EC-Karte das ist
es Plastik es sind Zahlen in einem
Computersystem Geld wird von einem
Computersystem Männer ein anderes
Computersystem verschoben es ist eine
einzige große Datenbank und dieses
digitale Geld verwenden wir jetzt um
Zahlungen zu tätigen wir verwenden es im
alltäglichen Wirtschaften
ich denke viele Leute in Großbritannien
denken wahrscheinlich dass die Regierung
oder die Zentralbank die Kontrolle über
das meiste im Umlauf befindliche Geld
hat und neues Geld in Umlauf bringt aber
das ist nicht der Fall es sind
Privatbanken die die überwiegende
Mehrheit das im Umlauf befindlichen
neuen Geldes schaffen und auch
entscheiden wie es verteilt wird
die
offizielle Terminologie für diesen
buchhaltungseintrag ist Geschäftsbank
Geld wenn Banken Kredite an die
Öffentlichkeit vergeben schaffen sie
neues Geschäftsbank Geld wenn ein Kunde
einen Kredit zurückzahlt wird das Geld
der Geschäftsbank vernichtet die Banken
behalten die Zinsen als Gewinn
es gibt viele Missverständnisse darüber
wie Banken funktionieren das copten
Center hat in einer Studie Leute befragt
wie sie dachten dass Banken
funktionieren rund 30% der Befragten
denken wenn sie ihr Geld auf die Bank
bringen bleibt es da und ist sicher man
kann verstehen warum weil jedes Kind ein
Sparschwein hat in dem es Geld
aufbewahrt in Zeiten der Not zerbricht
man es nimmt das Geld und gibt es aus
viele Menschen glauben dass das selber
auch auf das Bankwesen zutrifft ein
sicherer Ort um ihr Geld aufzubewahren
so dass es da ist wenn man es braucht
die restlichen 60% der Befragten gehen
davon aus dass ihr Geld dass sie auf die
Bank gebracht haben an jemand anderen
überwiesen wird er sich leihen will wir
haben also einen Rentner der sein ganzes
Leben lang spart und dessen Ersparnisse
an junge Leute die ein Haus kaufen
wollen verliehen werden aber so
funktionieren Banken nicht wirklich
es ist einfach ein Buchhaltung Banken
erschaffen Geld sie verleihen es nicht
wenn eine Bank ein Darlehen vergibt tut
sie einfach so als ob derjenige das Geld
eingezahlt hätte sie muss eine
zahlungsverbindlichkeit erfinden so wird
die Geldmenge geschaffen
Professor Richard Werner
derzeit liegen in Großbritannien
Geldschöpfung und Kontrolle vor allem in
den Händen der privaten Banken etwa 97
bis 98% des Geldes das erschaffen wird
könnte als bankschuldgeld bezeichnet
werden Banken bringen Geld im Grunde als
Darlehen im Umlauf das wird häufig nicht
verstanden
es ist keine Verschwörungstheorie es ist
keine Schnapsidee es ist für die Bank
von England den Prozess selbst
beschreibt wenn Banken Kredite vergeben
erschaffen sie neues Geld
die bei weitem größte Rolle bei der
Schaffung von Geld spielt der
Bankensektor wenn Banken Kredite
vergeben schaffen Sie zusätzliche
Einlagen für die die sich das Geld
leihen Paul Tacker Vizepräsident der
Bank auf England
einige wenige Ökonomen verstehen wie das
Geldsystem funktioniert falls man aber
nicht versteht wie das Geldsystem
funktioniert dann denkbar dass es gut
für die Wirtschaft ist wenn alle sparen
was wirklich passiert vorausgesetzt man
versteht wie das Geldsystem funktioniert
wenn jeder anfängt Geld zu sparen ist
dass die Geldmengen Umlauf schrumpft was
zu einer Rezession führt die meisten
Ökonomen haben also nicht das Gesamtbild
im Blick sie verstehen nicht alle Teile
des Systems sie verlassen sich auf
Annahmen allgemein akzeptierte Ansichten
ohne wirklich ins Detail zu gehen Geld
ist ein zentraler Aspekt der Wirtschaft
wenn jemand nicht versteht woher es
kommt wer es kreiert und wie es kreiert
wird wie kann so jemand die Wirtschaft
als Ganzes verstehen
wenn die überwiegende Mehrheit des
Geldes in Umlauf nicht Bargeld sondern
elektronisches Geld ist dann bekommt der
der das elektronische Geld schafft auch
den Erlös aus dieser Geldschöpfung die
Erschaffung elektronischen Geldes ist
selbstredend viel profitabler als die
Herstellung von Bargeld da dabei
keinerlei Herstellungskosten anfallen
während wir im Laufe eines Jahrzehntes
durch die Herstellung von Bargeld 18
Milliarden Pfund Gewinn gemacht haben
haben die Banken 1,2 Billionen Pfund
geschaffen
zwischen 1998 und 2007 verdreifachte
sich die britische Geldmenge 1,2
Billionen Pfund wurden von Banken
geschaffen während 18 Milliarden Pfund
vom Finanzministerium geschaffen worden
wenn ich oder wir oder positive money so
etwas sagen denken die Leute wie er sei
ein schlichtweg verrückt aber am 9 märz
2009 gab Ben burning der Präsident der
amerikanischen Zentralbank das erste
Interview das je von einem Präsidenten
der amerikanischen Zentralbank
ausgestrahlt wurde am Tag zuvor hatte er
a.i.g was noch nicht mal eine Bank
sondern eine Versicherungsgesellschaft
ist mit rund 160 Milliarden Dollar aus
der Patsche geholfen der Journalist
fragte ihn nun her Benecke wo haben Sie
denn die 160 Milliarden Dollar zur
Rettung von aid eigentlich herbekommen
behandeln sich die billion doris
bellater ist das Steuergeld das die Fett
ausgibt das sind keine Steuergelder die
Banken haben Konten bei der Fett ganz
ähnlich wie Sie ein Konto in einer
Geschäftsbank haben um an eine Bank zu
leihen müssen wir die Größe des Kontos
dass sie bei der Fett unterhält im
Computer dementsprechend nach oben
verändern es ist also dem Gelddrucken
viel ähnlicher als der Aufnahme eines
Kredits auch wenn es nicht dasselbe ist
Banken erschaffen neues Geld wenn sie
Kredite vergeben bestehende
Vermögenswerte kaufen oder Investitionen
auf eigene Rechnung machen was meist die
Erweiterung ihrer Vermögenswerte
beinhaltet wenn eine Bank Wertpapiere
wie Unternehmens oder Staatsanleihen
kauft rechnet sie die Anleihen zu ihren
Vermögenswerten hinzu und vergrößert die
Bankeinlagen des Unternehmens um die
entsprechende Summe neues Geschäftsbank
Geld kommt in Umlauf wenn Leute ihre
Bankkredite ausgeben
als ich von August 2009 bis zu den
Wahlen also in etwa acht neun Monaten an
Türen geklopft und versucht habe den
Menschen zu erklären wie das
Finanzsystem funktioniert stößt man auf
eine beinahe immanente Weigerung der
Menschen zu akzeptieren dass es eine
solche bizarre Situation überhaupt geben
kann nein das kann doch nicht sein was
sagen sie da Banken können doch nicht
Geld aus dem Nichts schaffen das ist
lächerlich das dürfen die nicht die
verleihen doch die Einlagen ihrer Kunden
die meisten Menschen haben eine
Vorstellung davon was Geld ist sie sind
ihren eigenen Umgang mit Geld gewohnt
und sie versuchen ihre Erfahrung damit
wie ihr kleiner haushaltwirtschaftet auf
die nationale Wirtschaft zu übertragen
und natürlich klappt das überhaupt nicht
bis 2008 beliebt sich das ausstehende
Kreditportfolio der von der Bank
geschaffenen Kredite auch bekannt als
Geschäftsbank Geld auf über 2 Millionen
Pfund
noch 1982 betrug das Verhältnis von
Banknoten und Münzen zu Bankeinlagen 1
zu 12 bis 2010 stieg das Verhältnis auf
eins zu 37 das heißt für jedes Pfund des
vom Finanzministerium geschaffenengeldes
gab es 37 Pfund von der Bank geschaffen
das Geld
10 Jahren vor der Krise von 2007 wuchs
die Geldmenge der britischen
Geschäftsbanken jedes Jahr um
7-10%. eine Wachstumsrate von 7%
entspricht einer Verdoppelung der
Geldmenge alle zehn Jahre
die Menge an Geld die sie aus dem Nichts
erschaffen ist einfach unglaublich 1,2
Billionen in den letzten 10 Jahren das
Geld wird entsprechend der Prioritäten
des Bankensektors verteilt nicht
entsprechend der Prioritäten der
Gesellschaft
der Bankensektor selbst wuchs von 1980
um 2,5 Millionen US-Dollar auf 40
Billionen US-Dollar nach Vermögenswerten
1980 war das globale Bankvermögen 20 Mal
so hoch wie die damalige Wirtschaft bis
2006 waren sie nach Angaben der
Vereinten Nationen 75 Mal so viel wert
wie die folgende Grafik zeigt bleiben
die gesamten bankaktiver der britischen
Banken als Prozentsatz des BIP bis Ende
der 1960er Jahre relativ stabil bei 50
bis 60 %. danach schossen sie dramatisch
in die Höhe
richtig Geld verdienen tut man in der
heutigen Welt nicht indem man
irgendetwas herstellt sondern durch
verschiedene Formen der Spekulation im
Grunde Geld aus Geld machen das ist bei
weitem die lukrativste und weit
verbreitete Form der wirtschaftlichen
Aktivität die es heute in der Welt gibt
heute sind Banken nicht mehr daran
gebunden wie viel sie verleihen können
und wie viele neuen Kredit sie aus dem
Nichts schaffen können sie sind allein
durch ihre eigene Kredit Bereitschaft
eingeschränkt
es gibt zwei wesentliche Probleme dabei
das Banken Geld erschaffen erstens die
Tatsache dass sie Geld erschaffen indem
sie Darlehen vergeben das garantiert
dass wir uns alles Geld für die
Wirtschaft von den Banken leihen müssen
also muss die Regierung um eine gesunde
wachsende Wirtschaft zu gewährleisten
Strategien entwickeln die ständig
wachsende Schulden ermöglicht
die Regierung kann nur zusätzliche
Kaufkraft schaffen indem sie sich selbst
und uns immer mehr verschuldet
das zweite große Problem Banken Geld
erschaffen zu lassen besteht darin dass
sie einen Anreiz haben immer mehr zu
erschaffen sie schaffen mehr Geld wenn
Sie einen Kredit vergeben sie bekommen
die Boni die Kommissionen und somit
Anreize so viel wie möglich zu verleihen
da muss man eine verkaufskultur
entwickeln und was haben sie gemacht sie
haben einen erstaunlichen Kerl
angestellt einen sehr netten Mann namens
Andy Hornby der kam von Ace um die Bank
in einer Art Supermarkt zu verwandeln
wenn Sie den Banken die Geldversorgung
anvertrauen wird die Geldmenge
unaufhörlich wachsen und somit die Höhe
der Verschuldung bis zu dem Punkt an dem
alles zusammenbricht sobald manche Leute
ihre Schulden nicht mehr bedienen können
dann hören sie auf Kredite zu vergeben
man hört Politiker und Journalisten
sagen dass wir über unsere Verhältnisse
gelebt haben wir sind von Schulden
abhängig geworden wir müssen unsere
Ausgaben kürzen und im Rahmen unserer
Möglichkeiten leben das ist im jetzigen
System nicht möglich der Grund dass alle
so verschuldet sind ist nicht dass sie
sich so leichtsinnig Geld geliehen haben
wir haben uns all das Geld nicht von
einem Heer Rentnern geliehen die ihr
ganzes Leben gespart haben Geld in
derzeitigen System ist Schuld es wird
erschaffen wenn Banken Kredite vergeben
der einzige Weg in derzeitigen System
Geld in Umlauf zu haben und mit dem
Unternehmen handeln können ist wenn wir
es bei den Banken leiden
das ist das genau Gegenteil von dem was
die konservative Partei heute behauptet
dass man nämlich erst Einsparungen
machen muss bevor man dem
Gesundheitssystem helfen kann und weil
Ökonomen diese Dinge durcheinander
gebracht haben sowohl in der Geldpolitik
als auch im ökonomischen denken und weil
Leute sich immer noch an die altmodische
Sichtweise Klammern dass man zunächst
sparen muss bevor man investieren kann
stecken wir überhaupt in dem Chaos dass
wir heute haben
einer der Gründe warum wir uns so schwer
tun das Bankensystem und die
Kreditschöpfung zu verstehen ist dass
wir die Schule verlassen und kein Geld
haben dann fangen wir als Klempner
Lehrling an die arbeiten den ganzen
Monat hart und am Ende des Monats
deponiert jemand Geld in unserer Bank
deshalb haben wir folgende Logik man
arbeitet und dann bekommt man Geld spart
was an in Wirklichkeit hätte man diesen
Job nie gekriegt wenn nicht zunächst
einmal ein Kredit vergeben worden wäre
es ist ein sehr wichtiges begriffliches
Missverständnis nicht nur die
Öffentlichkeit hat sich dessen schuldig
gemacht Ökonomen verstehen die Sache
auch nicht
eine
Geld entsteht nicht durch
wirtschaftliche Aktivitäten viele Leute
denen nicht begegnen gehen davon aus
dass aus diesem Prozess von Unternehmen
und Menschen machen was irgendwie Geld
entsteht aus dem Prozess das Menschen
was machen herstellen Anbau und
verkaufen produzieren das Geld dabei
einfach irgendwie entsteht es ist aber
wie das Öl im Auto man muss es hinein
tun
wenn ich David Cameron sagen höre dass
wir eine Wirtschaft brauchen die nicht
auf Schulden aufbaut sondern eine
Wirtschaft die auf Ersparnissen beruht
dann weiß er einfach nicht was er da
sagt es ist lächerlich es ist absolut
und zeigt dass er keinerlei Ahnung hat
wie das Geldsystem wirklich funktioniert
was er eigentlich sagt ist dass wir eine
Wirtschaft ohne Geld brauchen wenn alle
sparen würden würde das Geld
verschwinden
das ist das was eine bankenabschreibung
im wesentlichen ist Leute können ihre
Schulden nicht mehr bedienen was nichts
anderes ist als Geld das verschwindet
dass die Leute aber keine Schulden
aufnehmen sollen kann nur ein Scherz
sein das ist so eine amateurhafte
Auffassung davon wir unsere Wirtschaft
und unser Geldsystem funktioniert und
wie Geld überhaupt erschaffen wird ich
amüsiere mich darüber was die Leute so
von sich geben sie plappern einfach nach
was sie voneinander gelernt haben und
sagen immer das gleiche es geht mir
wirklich auf die Nerven wenn ich Leute
sagen höre wir brauchen mehr
Vorschriften wir müssen die Bank mehr
regulieren die Boni das ist alles nur
ein Ablenkungsmanöver weg von den
Symptomen einer größeren Krankheit sie
müssen sich das Geldsystem ansehen und
wie Geld erschaffen wird wenn wir keine
Schulden mehr wollen dann sagen wir im
Grunde dass wir kein Geld mehr wollen
dass wir eine geldlose Wirtschaft wollen
mit Ausnahme der drei Prozent die
schuldenfreier schaffen werden
das ist ein Paradox im gegenwärtigen
System wenn wir die Öffentlichkeit
weitere Schulden machen dann fließt mehr
Geld in die Wirtschaft und es gibt einen
Aufschwung es wird leichter Darlehen
aufzunehmen und die Leute verschulden
sich weiter der Zyklus setzt sich fort
es wird immer leichter sich zu
verschulden bis einige Leute
überschuldet sind sie können die
Schulden nicht mehr bedienen ihre
Hypothek nicht zurückzahlen das ist
zuerst bei den sogenannten subprime
Hypotheken in Amerika passiert das
verursacht eine Welle von
Zahlungsunfähigkeiten die sich auf die
gesamte Wirtschaft ausdehnt Banken
werden zahlungsunfähig ab da befinden
wir uns in einer Finanzkrise und die
Banken vergeben auf einmal keine Kredite
mehr im Aufschwung haben sie noch
übermäßig Kredite vergeben jetzt
vergeben Sie keine Kredite mehr was die
Rezession noch verschlimmert Menschen
verlieren ihre Arbeit und werden noch
abhängiger von Schulden einfach um zu
überleben wir haben ein System indem wir
Schulden aufnehmen müssen um überhaupt
eine Wirtschaft zu haben wir müssen
Schulden bei den Banken machen und das
garantiert gewaltige Gewinne für die
Banken
ander
S
und ich habe schon früher gesagt keine
Rückkehr zu Boom und Bast
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die nettokreditvergabe der Banken muss
für immer steigen
wir zahlen Zinsen auf jedes einzelne
Pfund selbst wenn du denkst dass das
Geld Dir gehört zahlt jemand irgendwo
Zinsen auf dieses Geld
das Bankensystem hat so einen großen
Einfluss auf die Welt aber nur weil es
unsere Nation mit Geld versorgt wir
müssen es schützen wir müssen es
subventionieren wir müssen ihnen
erlauben weiterzumachen weil die
Katastrophe eines Banken Zusammenbruchs
uns alle enorm betrifft jeder der sagt
wir hätten die Bank nicht retten sollen
der versteht das Wesen unseres
Geldsystems nicht das wäre wie eine
große Menge unseres Geldes einfach zu
vernichten andererseits erhält die
Rettung der Banken ein System aufrecht
das sowieso nie funktionieren wird egal
was wir tun wir werden immer diesen
Zyklus haben bis wir die Geld
Erschaffung vom Bankwesen trennen dann
können die Banken machen was sie wollen
Sie wären ein normales Unternehmen wie
jedes andere auch
es gibt dabei auch einen wichtigen
demokratischen Aspekt private
gewinnorientierte Banken erschaffen bis
zu 200 Milliarden im Jahr und Pumpen es
in die Wirtschaft wie es Ihnen beliebt
egal ob sie es sind toxische Derivate
Pumpen oder in Immobilienblasen wodurch
einfach nur die Wohnungen teurer werden
200 Milliarden von flossen im Jahr 2007
in die Wirtschaft erschaffen aus dem
Nichts in was dieses Geld investiert
wird bestimmt die Ausrichtung unserer
Wirtschaft wenn wir also jemandem schon
erlauben Geld aus dem nicht zu
erschaffen sollten wir zumindest die
demokratische Kontrolle darüber haben
wofür das Geld ausgegeben wird wollen
wir das Geld lieber in das
Gesundheitswesen investieren oder um
etwas für den Umweltschutz zu tun oder
die Armut zu mindern oder wollen wir es
eher dafür ausgeben um Häuser teurer zu
machen sodass es sich keiner mehr
leisten kann in einem Haus zu wohnen
zu sein
you you
man kann es als eine super Subvention
für Banken verstehen für das Recht Geld
zu schaffen es sollte eigentlich der
Allgemeinheit dienen und demokratisch
ausgegeben werden
Zentralbank Reservewährung
das also
Cash es gibt noch eine weitere Art von
Geld sozusagen elektronisches Bargeld es
ist eine Geldform die Geschäftsbanken
gebrauchen um untereinander Zahlungen
durchzuführen Banken wollen keine
riesigen Mengen Geld herumtragen weil es
gefährlich unbequem und teuer ist für
solche Geldmengen muss man einen
Sicherheitsdienst anheuern deswegen
bezahlen sie sich gegenseitig mit einer
elektronischen Form von Bargeld in der
Branche bekannt als Zentralbank Reserven
dieses elektronische Bargeld liegt auf
konnten bei der Bank of England als
einfacher Bürger hat man keinen Zugriff
auf dieses elektronische Geld
man kann bei der Bank of England kein
Konto eröffnen sie verkaufen dieses
Zentralbank Geld an die Banken sie
schaffen es aus dem Nichts und damit
kaufen Sie Anleihen von den
Geschäftsbanken diese Anleihe bei der
Sicherung Staatsschulden Hand löst die
Geschäftsbank bei der Bank of England
ein im Gegenzug tippt die Bank of
England ein paar neue Ziffern in das
Konto der Bank bei der Bank of England
im Endeffekt erschaffen sie Zentralbank
Reserven aus dem
nichts“reserven indem sie das verfügbare
Guthaben auf dem Konto der
vergleichsbank bei der Bank of England
erhöht die Abwicklungsbank hinterlegt im
Gegenzug Anleihen oder verkauft
vermögenswerter als Sicherheiten für die
Reserven
insgesamt halten 46 Banken central reser
Accounts bei der Bank of England
kleinere oder ausländische Banken
unterhalten konnten bei einer dieser 46
Banken damit sie Zahlungen in Pfund
Sterling annehmen oder tätigen können
vor März 2009 fragte die Bank auf
England jede der großen
abwicklungsbanken wie viele Reserve
Währung sie benötigt die
abwicklungsbanken würden dann eine
Anleihe gegen die Reservewährung
tauschen und zustimmen die Anleihe für
einen bestimmten Betrag zu einem
bestimmten zukünftigen Zeitpunkt
zurückzukaufen
die abwicklungsbanken würden dann Zinsen
zum Basis oder Leitzinssatz für die von
ihnen gehaltenen Zentralbank Reserven
erhalten
seit der Krise sind die
zentralbank-reserven der
abwicklungsbanken dramatisch in die Höhe
geschossen
Bedeutung der Zentralbank Reserven
wenn Bankkunden Geld von Ihrem Konto auf
das Konto einer anderen Person
überweisen findet ein Prozess namens
interdate clearing statt der Betrag der
zentralen Reservewährung den Bank a bei
der Bank of England hat wird um den
entsprechenden Betrag reduziert den Bank
B erhält
dies ist die Bedeutung der
zentralbankwährung für die Banken
wenn vor der Kreditkrise eine Bank bei
der Bank of England keine zentralen
Reserven hatte um ihren Verpflichtungen
nachzukommen musste sich die Bank
Reserven von anderen Banken mit Zinsen
leihen
es wird nur die Reservewährung der
Zentralbank bewegt Geschäftsbank Geld
wird einfach abgezogen und hinzugefügt
wenn Sie etwas bei ebay verkaufen wissen
sie dass das Geschäft nicht
abgeschlossen ist bis das Geld auf ihrem
Konto ist die meisten Menschen wollen
das Geld auf ihrem Konto sehen bevor sie
das Geschäft abschließen die Banken sind
auch nicht anders sie wollen ihr Geld
auf ihrem Konto bei der Bank auf England
sehen bevor sie ein Geschäft als
abgeschlossen betrachten wenn Sie ein
Haus von jemandem kaufen der bei einer
anderen Bank ist als sie dann
beauftragen Sie nachdem Sie 250.000 für
ein Haus ausgegeben haben ihre Bank
damit Geld an die Bank des
hausverkäufers zu überweisen die Bank
wiederum weiß die Bank of England an
250.000 aus deren Konto bei der Bank auf
England auf das konnte der Bank des
hausverkäufers zu verschieden
dieses Geld bewegt sich tatsächlich von
einem zum anderen Konto bei der Bank auf
England wenn sich das Geld bewegt hat
dann erst gehen die Banken davon aus
dass diese Zahlung getätigt wurde sie
handeln nicht wirklich in der Art von
Geld die wir in unseren Kunden haben sie
Hand ELN in dieser speziellen Währung
die nur bei der Zentralbank genutzt
werden kann
es gibt Millionen von Menschen im ganzen
Land die sich alle gegenseitig Geld
überweisen indem sie nur wenige große
Banken benutzen diese Banken können eine
Strichliste auf ihren Computersystemen
führen und in der Regel heben sich viele
der Bewegungen am Ende des Tages
gegenseitig auf die fünf Großbanken
Aries Lloyds age SBC Barclays und
Santander halten über 85% aller Einlagen
da ist eine begrenzte Anzahl von Banken
im System gibt kann das Zentralbankgeld
nur in einem geschlossenen Kreislauf um
sie herum bewegt werden das Geld
zirkuliert immer und immer wieder durch
dieses System und wenn man darüber
nachdenkt könnte eine ein Pfund Münze
verwendet werden um eine Milliarde Pfund
an Zahlungen zu leisten wenn Sie eine
Milliarde Mal in Umlauf gebracht wurde
und das ist das System dass sie jetzt
haben sie haben einen kleinen Pool von
echtem Geld der nur um das System
herumgeht und es wird verwendet um eine
große Menge an Zahlungen in unserem
Namen zu tätigen kurz vor der Krise
befanden sich nur 20 Milliarden Pfund
auf den Konten der Zentralbank
wenn sie nicht genug von diesem
Zentralbankgeld haben dann können Sie
effektiv keine Zahlungen leisten und
wenn das passiert dann zerbricht
ziemlich schnell das ganze System sie
Bank of England hat also die
Verantwortung sicherzustellen dass genug
von diesem Geld im System ist
[Musik]
die Anforderungen an Banken eine
bestimmte Menge an Reserven zu halten
haben sich seit 1947 viele Male geändert
zu dieser Zeit mussten die Banken ein
mindestverhältnis von 32 % der Reserven
Bargeld oder Staatsanleihen zu Einlagen
einhalten im Jahr 2006 wurde das
Korridor System eingeführt bei dem die
Banken jeden Monat ihre eigenen
reserveziele festlegen konnten
[Musik]
die Regeln änderten sich erneut im März
2009 als die Bank of England die
quantitative Lockerung einführte die
quantitative Lockerung gibt den
Abwicklungsbank Banken die zentrale
Reservewährung kostenlos
die Zentralbank Währung ist das was im
Mindestreserve Modell als echtes Geld
bezeichnet wird aber Tatsache ist dass
die Banken so viel davon haben können
wie Sie wollen und die Zentralbank
Währung selbst ist eine Form von Fiat
Geld das durch nichts gedeckt ist in
Folge dessen gibt es keine sinnvolle
Mindestreserve mehr
eine kurze Geschichte des Geldes
viele
history
wenn sie sich die Geschichte der letzten
150 Jahre anschauen dann fängt es mit
der Entwicklung des Goldstandards an der
in den 1880er und 1890er Jahren ins
Blickfeld gerät dabei koppeln sich
Länder an einen bestimmten Goldwert
schaffen ein Abkommen diesen Wert
beizubehalten und Gold untereinander zu
handeln um sicherzustellen dass die
Balance stimmt außerdem um zu versuchen
die Aktivitäten der eigenen Wirtschaft
einzuschränken oder zu erweitern um
sicherzustellen dass das Gleichgewicht
zu diesem Fixpreis beibehalten wird das
alles Bericht nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg
zusammen das ganze bricht auseinander
eine massive Verlagerung im
internationalen Währungssystem die nicht
wirklich gelöst wird bis zum Abkommen
von Woods in dem alles an den Dollar und
der Dollar an Gold gekoppelt wird
also ein Schritt entfernt von einer
Golddeckung oder zu einer Art von
solidem wahren Geld hinter dem Papier
und Kredit Geld dass wir alle nutzen
sozusagen einen Schritt davon entfernt
nach Hiroshima fragte sich Tokio wann
die nächste Atombombe fallen würde
das haben sie nicht lange gefragt
[Musik]
1944 in Breton Woods haben die USA und
Großbritannien begonnen zu verhandeln
wie sie die Weltwirtschaft und das
globale Währungssystem regieren könnten
dabei haben sie die Weltbank den IWF und
noch ein paar andere Institutionen
entworfen um die globalen Währungen zu
regulieren und es gab noch einen
Goldstandard aber dieser Goldstandard
war an den Dollar gebunden alles Gold
der Welt zog von London nach Fort Knox
und sämtliche Währung in der Welt waren
an den Dollar gebunden dieses System
wurde entwickelt um mögliche
Ungleichgewichte zu managen und um
kreditknappheit zu verhindern bei
Staaten handelt es sich bei
kreditknappheit um mein Handels Defizit
sie können ihre Rechnungen nicht mehr
bezahlen und die Währung bricht ein die
Währungen wurden verwaltet und das
System war stabil solange die Amerikaner
die Rolle des aufpassers spielten
wer weiß wie die Geschichte ausging
die Menge an Geld also die nötig war um
den Vietnamkrieg zu bezahlen genau
darauf wollte ich hinaus Ölpreis Schocks
waren ein weiterer Fall die Amerikaner
respektierten ihre Rolle des
Währungssystems zu verwalten nicht mehr
sie haben den Wert ihrer eigenen Währung
aufgeblasen die eigentlich gekoppelt
sein sollte gekoppelt an Gold wie jeder
andere Währung was haben die Franzosen
da unternommen die Franzosen waren ein
wenig entsorge dass Präsident nix nicht
ganz ehrlich war sie waren besorgt
darüber dass es nächsten Geld druckte
obwohl er das nicht sollte und sie waren
besorgt dass es nicht genug Gold gab den
Wechselkurs des französischen France
einzulösen also schicken Sie einen
Kriegsschiff in den Hafen von New York
um ausgesprochen freundlich zu fragen ob
sie nicht bitte Ihr Geld zurück haben
könnten
Sie Ihr Gold zurückbekommen haben sie
nicht und das brettenwood System fand
sein Ende an diesem Punkt betreten wir
die moderne Ehre des Finanzsystems
fehlt Geld ein Tauschmittel dass der
Emittent nicht verspricht in einer Ware
einzulösen und das auch Vertrauen
basiert
historisch gesehen war die Geldschöpfung
an eine wahre gebunden oft an Gold aber
heute ist sie an nichts gebunden
das bedeutet dass es nichts gibt was
unser Geld absichert dieses Stück Papier
ist nur ein Stück Papier was bleibt uns
wenn Geld auf nichts passiert warum
glauben wir dass es überhaupt einen Wert
hat
weil wir es immer noch umtauschen können
das Wort Kredit kommt aus dem
Lateinischen und steht für glauben
seit dem Zusammenbruch des doller
Goldstandards im Jahr 1971 und der
Deregulierung des Finanzsystems ist die
Geldschöpfung exponentiell gewachsen
dass sich in Davos trifft hat sich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt auf die Notwendigkeit
geeinigt den Kreditrahmen der
Weltwirtschaft um 100 Billionen
US-Dollar zu erweitern eine Billion hat
12 Nullen 100 Billionen ist eine 1
gefolgt von 14 Nullen
ist
sie glauben dass diese Kredit Expansion
einen Boom auslösen wird weil es jetzt
mehr Geld in der Wirtschaft gibt mit dem
Investitionen getätigt werden können
es ist faszinierend diese Entstehung der
digitalen Währungen wie sie wirklich
alles verändert hat weil es Privatbanken
völlig entfesselt hat das Geldsystem zu
dominieren und so zu gestalten dass es
für sie arbeitet und für die Leute die
Privatbanken leiten
Wachstum und Inflation wenn sie bei der
derzeitigen Konstellation eine
erwachsene Wirtschaft haben wollen dann
bedeutet das auch wachsende Schulden das
ist etwas das nur sehr sehr wenige
Menschen verstehen vor allem aber keine
Politiker die wiederum die Wirtschaft
managen was ein beängstigender Gedanke
ist
Bruttoinlandsprodukt der Markt wird alle
in einem Land in einem bestimmten
Zeitraum produzierten Endprodukte und
Dienstleistungen
wenn die Geldmenge wächst steht mehr
Geld zur Verfügung das in produktive
Wege investiert werden kann es kann
jedoch auch verwendet werden um damit zu
spielen und die Vermögenspreise in die
Höhe zu treiben
eine Erhöhung der Geldmenge ein
wahrscheinlicher relativer Anstieg der
Wirtschaftstätigkeit
die Auswirkungen einer raschenkredit
Expansion
ist ein Anstieg der allgemeinen Niveaus
der Preise für Waren und
Dienstleistungen in einer
Volkswirtschaft über einen bestimmten
Zeitraum wenn das allgemeine Preisniveau
steigt kauft jede Währungseinheit
weniger Waren und Dienstleistungen wenn
die Geldmenge wächst und mehr Währung
zur Verfügung steht steht mehr Geld für
Investitionen zur Verfügung was zu
Wachstum führen kann aber es steht auch
mehr Geld für den Kauf von Waren und
Spekulationen zur Verfügung was zu
Inflation führt
[Musik]
im Wesentlichen ist Inflation das was
passiert wenn zu viel Geld zu wenigen
Gütern und Dienstleistungen nachjagt so
dass es zu viel Geld für die
tatsächliche Produktion der Wirtschaft
gibt
in den sieben Jahren zwischen 2000 und
2007 hat sich die Geldmenge verdoppelt
und die Bank of England hatte den
Eindruck es unter Kontrolle zu haben
weil sie sich dort sagten dass die
Preise nicht so stark stiegen sie haben
aber nur die Preise in den Tante
emmerläden vor Ort berücksichtigt
Immobilienpreise haben sie nicht
berücksichtigt obwohl Immobilien die
größte Ausgabe sind die die meisten
Menschen tätigen
viele westliche Länder subventionieren
stark die landwirtschaftliche Produktion
was dazu führt dass Preise und Inflation
niedrig gehalten werden
steigende Häuserpreise können Ihnen
vielleicht das Gefühl geben dass sie
reicher sind aber dass ich ihr Vermögen
vergrößert hat den Effekt dass das
Vermögen ihrer Kinder abnimmt es
entsteht also kein Nettogewinn an
Vermögen denn ihre Kinder müssen
tatsächlich umso mehr zahlen wenn Sie
ein Haus kaufen wollen es entsteht also
keine netto Wertsteigerung sie werden
noch mehr verdienen müssen sie müssen
noch mehr Schulden aufnehmen
also keinen zusätzlichen bip-wert für
die Wirtschaft was sie tun ist Reichtum
an diejenigen Leute zu verteilen die
bereits Häuser haben das heißt die
reicheren Menschen und nehmen es ärmeren
Menschen die es sich nicht leisten
können auf dem Eigenheim Markt
mitzumischen zuzulassen dass ich
Immobilienpreise aufblähen ist ein
weiteres Beispiel für eine äußerst
regressive Politik dadurch hat zwar
jeder irgendwie das Gefühl die Dinge
laufen ganz gut und die Leute geben mehr
Geld für andere Dinge aus indem sie ihre
Immobilien beleihen aber es schafft
keine neuen Arbeitsplätze es verbessert
die Qualität unserer Wirtschaft nicht es
hilft unsere Handelsbilanz nicht es
verringert das Haushaltsdefizit nicht es
ist ein Nullsummenspiel
august 2011 waren 85 ein halb Prozent
der Bankkredite von Verbrauchern als
Hypotheken auf Wohnungen gesichert
wenn Sie jemanden haben der Geld
erschafft das nur für eine Sache
ausgegeben werden kann nämlich das
Wohnen dann wird der Preis für dieses
Ding steigen zwischen 2000 und 2010
schufen sie über eine Billion Pfund
neues Geld 500 Milliarden Pfund allein
in den drei Jahren vor der Krise deshalb
stiegen die Hauspreise so stark die
Häuser selbst waren nicht besonders es
war einfach all das Geld das in diesem
Markt gepumpt wurde
wenn Geld in die Wirtschaft fließt dann
geht viel Geld in Immobilien Hypotheken
zum Beispiel das ist eine Steigerung der
Geldmenge in der Wirtschaft ohne eine
entsprechende Steigerung an Aktivität
Leistung oder BIP es sind Ausgaben die
das BIP nicht beeinflussen das
verursacht Inflation in Großbritannien
hatten wir es im Überfluss
wir hatten diesen massiven
Immobilienboom die Hauptursache für den
Immobilienboom meiner Meinung nach ist
die riesige Menge an von Banken
geschaffenen spekulativen Krediten die
in Immobilien flossen wenn Häuser
billiger wären wären sie einfacher zu
bauen mehr davon würden gebaut werden es
gäbe weniger riesige Häuser mit kaum
Menschen drin London wäre nicht das
Zentrum einer opulenten spekulativen
Orgie wo alle reichen Menschen auf der
Welt Eigentum besitzen wird
während in erster Linie Orte in denen
man wohnt nicht in die man investiert es
ist wichtig zu bedenken dass sie während
sie eine Bank Optionen haben wenn sie
einen Kredit vergeben wenn Sie den
Kredit an ein kleines Unternehmen
vergeben wissen Sie um die relativ hohe
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass der Kredit nicht
zurückgezahlt wird da die Eigentümer des
kleinen Unternehmens eine beschränkte
Haftung haben wenn das Unternehmen
pleite geht kriegen sie als Bank nicht
zurück das ist ein ziemlich hohes Risiko
verglichen damit es jemandem zu leihen
der eine Sicherheit bietet wie ein Haus
wie eine Hypothek
kann es gibt also einen einfachen Anreiz
für Banken mehr Geld er in Immobilien
als in kleine Unternehmen zu stecken das
wird zu einem echten Problem wenn Sie
das auf die ganze Wirtschaft übertragen
denn dadurch gibt es einen Anreiz Geld
eher in spekulativer als in produktive
Investitionen zu stecken
wir müssen uns also überlegen wie wir
ein Geldsystem schaffen das spekulative
und produktiver Investitionen besser in
Einklang bringt die Regierung zeigt
äußerst wenig Bereitschaft den
Wohnungsmarkt zu regulieren und die
Menge an Geld zu regulieren das Banken
in Immobilien stecken
wir entscheiden nicht wer und wofür
Kredite vergeben werden wir überlassen
diese Entscheidung im Prinzip ein paar
Typen in einer Bank
eine kurze Geschichte der blasen
eine Blase entsteht bei sehr hoher
Inflation des Preises einer bestimmten
Ware oder Dienstleistung innerhalb
kurzer Zeit
die erste aufgezeichnete Blase war die
tulpenblase von 1637 die Bedeutung der
Sache mit den Tulpen ist dass wir hier
die erste Finanzblase und deren Crash
überhaupt haben die Begeisterung für
Tulpen schwarze Tulpen galten als sein
mystisches ideal dafür was jemand durch
Kultivierung über viele Generationen
genetisch manipulieren konnte wurde in
den 1630er Jahren zu einer Manie in der
Niederlanden ihnen war nicht bewusst
dass viele der Muster gar nicht
genetisch waren sondern durch einen
Virus verursacht wurden aber sie
handelten damit so lange bis eine
tulpensibel das Zehnfache dessen Wert
war was ein Mensch damals in den
Niederlanden im Jahr im Durchschnitt
verdiente
es gab einen futuresmarkt mit Tulpen
Zwiebeln weil man sie ja jetzt pflanzt
ohne zu wissen was aus dem Boden kommen
wird also bereits vor 400 Jahren sehen
wir dass ein Geldsystem oder einen
Finanzsystem nicht ist was da draußen im
abstrakten im Äther existiert sondern
etwas das mit Staaten macht Handel und
deren Wechselwirkung zu tun hat
im Gegensatz zu Tulpen die einen
überflüssiges Luxusgut sind sind Häuser
eine Notwendigkeit und ein Luxus
zugleich und als solche sind sie ein
ideales Vehikel für Geld und die
Schöpfung einer Blase eine Behausung ist
vielleicht der wertvollste Besitz den
die meisten Menschen anstreben
Immobilienpreise auf diese Art
aufzublasen ermöglicht es einer Nation
ihre Geldmenge zu vergrößern ohne die
Inflationsdaten zu beeinflussen die
dadurch gewonnene zusätzliche Kaufkraft
erhöht das Wahrgenommene Vermögen im
Vergleich zu anderen Nationen und
schafft dadurch relative macht es ist
ein Weg die monetäre Macht zu steigern
ohne in das produktive Wachstum der
Industrie zu investieren
und Amerika sind sicherlich
herausragende Beispiele dafür dies sind
Länder mit einem sehr hohen Anteil an
privatem Hauseigentum es gibt also eine
gute Basis um solch eine Politik
hinterrücks zu versuchen ich glaube es
war ziemlich offensichtlich im Fall der
USA als Ellen Greens Bahn als Chef der
Federer Reserve Ende der 90er mit einem
Börsencrash konfrontiert bewusst die
Zinssätze auf nahezu Null
zusammendrückte jeder kann Kredite
aufnehmen günstig es ist besonders
leicht ein Haus zu beleihen da es sich
um einen Vermögenswert handelt bei dem
die Bank sagen kann okay wir leihen ihn
nicht einfach Geld ohne Sicherheit sie
haben ja ein Haus was tolle ist weil wir
es in Besitz nehmen können das werden
sie ihnen beim Abschluss der Hypothek
zwar nicht sagen aber Sie können es tun
und diese Blase ist dann genau das was
die Expansion führt so wie in den USA
und Großbritannien wo in den nächsten 10
Jahren etwas ähnliches passiert es ist
auch ein Spiegelbild der tiefer
liegenden Schwäche dieser Regierungen
ihnen fehlt einfach Stille und
möglicherweise auch die Fähigkeit wobei
ich denke dass es mehr auf den Willen
ankommt die Finanzmärkte herauszufordern
das Großkapital herauszufordern und zu
sagen dass wir jetzt etwas anders machen
und ihr müsst mitziehen weil wir
demokratisch gewählt worden und ihr nun
mal nicht und wir haben ein Mandat dazu
und wir werden das jetzt umsetzen
denken Sie daran dass alles Teil des
Plans ist was maulst du rum du hast doch
dafür gestimmt
was in den Niederlanden passierte zu
einer Zeit als sie versuchten von
Spanien unabhängig zu werden und genug
Geld aufzubringen um eine Armee
auszuheben um sich zu befreien war
finanztechnische Innovation sie haben
öffentliche Lotterien eingeführt um Geld
aufzutreiben sie hatten öffentliche
Abgaben das war die Idee die zu
öffentlichen Beteiligungen führte ein
Stück vom Kuchen in das jeder
investieren konnte das bedeutet dass in
den 1630er Jahren etwa zwei Drittel der
Bevölkerung in Tulpenzwiebeln
investierte nach der Unabhängigkeit
wurden diese Instrumente zur
Finanzierung der Expansion angewendet
wie konnte sich ein so kleines Land
gegen so viel größere Länder behaupten
Spanien und Portugal zum Beispiel deren
Imperium anders als die Niederlande
bereits seit über einem Jahrhundert
Bestand hatten wie konnten sie
konkurrieren auf Grundlage welche
Ressource sie hatten ein effizienteres
weiterentwickeltes und breiter
angelegtes Finanzsystem die Instrumente
die sie erfunden haben erlaubten es
ihnen zu dem Zeitpunkt schneller mehr
Geld aufzubringen als jeder andere
unglaublich aber wahr
wie kann Inflation vermieden werden
Inflation kann vermieden werden wenn die
Menge das Geldes das in die Wirtschaft
fließt reguliert wird so dass sie die
tatsächliche Leistung der Wirtschaft
nicht übersteigt
der beste Weg das sicherzustellen gilt
nur für produktive Investitionen zu
schaffen für produktive Güter und
Dienstleistungen so fließt Geld in den
Aufbau eines kleinen Unternehmens das
Arbeitsplätze schafft das zusätzliche
Kaufkraft schafft was bedeutet dass es
keine Inflation gibt
fast alle Zentralbanken in der
Geschichte haben eine Form der direkten
kreditregulierung betrieben die
Zentralbank bestimmt zunächst das
gewünschte nominale BIP-Wachstum dann
berechnet sie die notwendige Menge an
Kreditschöpfung um das zu erreichen dann
wird die so geschaffene Kreditmenge an
die verschiedenen Banken und Arten von
Banken und die industriellen Sektoren
verteilt unproduktiver Kredit würde
unterdrückt damit wäre es schwierig oder
gar unmöglich an Bankkredite für enorme
rein spekulative Transaktionen zu kommen
wie die immensen bankfinanzierungen für
Hedgefonds heutzutage die Weltbank
erkannte in einer Studie aus dem Jahr
1993 an dass dieser Mechanismus aus
Intervention und kreditverteilung in
Herzen des ostasiatischen
Wirtschaftswunders
Lago es gibt alle möglichen Dinge die
Regierungen in der Vergangenheit getan
haben die Beispiele die einem sofort
einfallen sind südkorea Japan oft in
Ostasien wo Regierungen darauf
ausgerichtet sind die wir läuft in ein
Gleichgewicht zu bringen sie suchen
Sektoren aus und entscheiden wo
Investitionen getätigt werden sollten
das muss auch bald in Großbritannien
passieren weil wir eine
nachfragebedingte Rezession haben und
nicht so sehr eine Krise des Angebots
sie brauchen ein System in dem Kredit in
produktive Unternehmen fließt wo Kredit
in den Bau eines
hochgeschwindigkeitsschienennetzes
gesteckt wird wo Kredite zum Bau von
Häusern zur Verfügung stehen anstatt
Leuten Geld zu geben um den Preis der
Häuser in die Höhe zu treiben es ist
wirklich so einfach dass derzeitige
System ist nicht darauf ausgerichtet das
zu tun
die Schaffung von Geld durch
Privatbanken für den nicht produktiven
gebraucht verursacht eine reale
Inflation und ist als solche eine Steuer
auf die Kaufkraft des Tauschmittels
Minderung des Lebensstandards
die Zahlen für Großbritannien sind
ziemlich krass die mittleren
Durchschnitts realen kommen sind für die
meisten Menschen in den letzten acht
Jahren geschrumpft sie sinken jetzt
gerade stark da wir in die Rezession
rutschen die heftigste seit den 1930er
Jahren also singt das Realeinkommen
von der Bank geschaffene Fiat Währung
ermöglicht es den Privatbanken Reichtum
aus der Wirtschaft zu saugen und führt
im Laufe der Zeit zu einer allmählichen
Senkung des Lebensstandards wenn die
Menschen ärmer werden werden sie noch
abhängiger von Schulden und dies zu
einer Zeit in der sich Effizienz und
Mechanisierung dramatisch verbessert
haben
in den 1960er Jahren haben wir erwartet
dass ein Zeitalter der Muse anbricht den
Fernsehsendungen haben sie gefragt was
die Leute mit ihrer Freizeit anstellen
und jetzt arbeiten mehr Menschen härter
als je zuvor
sie geben mehr Geld aus als je zuvor was
natürlich toll aussieht jeder gibt mehr
Geld aus aber wenn man nicht wirklich
was davon hat was man ausgibt wenn Sie
Ihr Geld für Kinderbetreuung für das
Pendeln zur Arbeit und dergleichen
ausgeben müssen Kosten die die Menschen
früher nicht aufbringen mussten weil sie
zur Arbeit laufen konnten ein Mitglied
der Familie konnte zu Hause bleiben und
sich um den Haushalt kümmern dann geht
es einem nicht wirklich besser
laufen
jeder steht heutzutage unter solch einem
enormen Druck ich bin mir bewusst dass
meine vier Neffen und nicht ein schwere
Zeiten vor sich haben sie werden sehr
hart arbeiten müssen nur mein Dach über
dem Kopf zu behalten um überhaupt ein zu
haben
die Menschen werden netto immer ärmer
weil die Preise immer weiter steigen
weil dieses ganze Spielgeld von den
Banken ins System gepumpt wird und sie
erzeugen alle diese Schulden zur
gleichen Zeit in der die Preise steigen
und die Dinge immer teurer werden
Verschulden wir uns immer mehr und unser
Wohlstand und das was wir tatsächlich
für unsere Arbeit kriegen wird immer
weniger
sie können nichts gegen Armut
unternehmen wenn Sie ein Finanz- und
Geldsystem haben das Geld von den Armen
an die sehr reichen verteilt jeder
Versuch einer Verteilung in die
entgegengesetzte Richtung ist wie gegen
den Wind zu pinkeln nehmen Sie die
zunehmende Ungleichheit eine
offensichtliche Möglichkeit Ungleichheit
zu bekämpfen ist eine Umverteilung durch
Steuern sie besteuern die Reichen und
geben etwas Geld an die Armen sie
verschieben ein bisschen Geld auf Skala
das ist gut und schön aber wenn sie
völlig übersehen dass es eine weitere
Umverteilung gibt die den Armen Geld
nimmt und es den Reichen gibt dann
werden sie die Ungleichheit nie in den
Griff bekommen
ein auf Schulden basierendes System
stellt sicher dass es für jedes Pfund an
Geld ein Pfund Schulden gibt diese
Schulden landen am Ende bei den Armen
der unteren Mittelschicht diese Menschen
sitzen am Ende auf den Schuldenbergen
und Zahlen Zinsen auf das Geld das
fließt dann zurück in den Bankensektor
und wird unter den Leuten verteilt die
in der City oder an der Wall Street
arbeiten insgesamt gesehen verteilt das
System Geld von den ärmeren an die
Reichen verteilt Geld aus den ärmeren
Regionen Großbritanniens zurück an die
City of London und es war Teil Geld von
den kleinen Betrieben den kleinen
Fabriken ganz Großbritannien zurück an
den Finanzsektor werden
wir haben ein System bei dem die
Aktivität tatsächlich unter dem gleichen
Dach stattfindet wie die gleiche
Organisation die dafür verantwortlich
ist von der Zusammenstellung von
Kreditnehmern und Kreditgebern das heißt
einer Bank zu profitieren eine Bank
schafft also die Geldmenge unserer
Nation und vergibt Kredite für den
Profit
making
die Regierung kann nicht zulassen dass
das Bankensystem zusammenbricht denn
wenn sie es täte würden über 97% des
gesamten Geldes verschwinden deshalb
wird im Krisenfall das Risiko auf den
Steuerzahler übertragen aber auch in
normalen Zeiten erhalten Banken
zahlreiche Garantien und Vorteile die
über das Recht auf Geldschöpfung
hinausgehen
Bill ich weiß übrigens dass die Bank of
America eine sehr große Bank ist
zufällig habe ich selbst 32 Dollar dort
liegen welche Garantie habe ich dass das
Geld auch sicher ist
nun alle Einlagen bis zu 10.000 Dollar
sind bei der Bundesregierung in
Washington versichert ist das eine
Garantie hast du gehört dass die
Bundesregierung mit 280 Milliarden in
den Miesen ist
Banken erhalten große Sicherheitsnetze
von der Regierung der Steuerzahler
garantiert 85.000 Pfund an
einlagensicherheit und die Bank auf
England bietet Liquidität Sicherheit für
den Fall dass einer Bank die Zentralbank
Reserven ausgehen
jemand schrieb das eine große
Investmentbank wie ein gigantischer
Vampir Tintenfisch ist der sich um das
Antlitz der Menschheit geschlungen hat
Politiker hypnotisierend die mit Geld
nach den Banken werfen an keinerlei
Bedingungen geknüpft egal was für ein
Schaden angerichtet wird den Planeten
zerstört Kürzungen erzwingen bei Dingen
die das Leben besser machen
auf Wiedersehen Schulen auf Wiedersehen
Spielplätze auf Wiedersehen
Arbeitsplätze
der Bank ist
die Banker die wir rausgehauen haben
haben sich im Anschluss Boni gegönnt die
größer waren als die erste Runde der
öffentlichen Ausgabenkürzungen
Großbritannien allein gab den Banken
mehr Geld als es kostet einen Mann sechs
Mal auf den Mond zu schießen
Sex times
where money go wo ist unser Geld hin wer
lässt den Banken das durchgehen
warum können Vampir Tintenfische jemals
nützlich sein keine Regierung ist bisher
mutig genug sie zu zähmen
vielleicht brauchen Sie einen Plan
die große Wende die Rückeroberung
unserer Banken
immer mehr Schulden
das spending
ist ein Versuch der Regierung Schulden
von Ihrem Konto auf das der
Öffentlichkeit zu verlagern das ist die
Antwort der Regierung auf die
Bankenrettung und die ist notwendig in
einem auf Schulden basierenden
Geldsystem in dem ein Anstieg der
Kaufkraft das Ergebnis steigender
Schulden ist und in dem eine
Diversifizierung der Schulden allgemeine
Stabilität und Mark Vertrauen herstellt
Maßnahmen wie eine Erhöhung der
Studiengebühren und die Privatisierung
öffentlicher Dienstleistungen
Vermögenswerte und industriefolgen
demselben Muster the problem
das Problem mit dem wir konfrontiert
sind ist dass es eine Übertragung der
öffentlichen Schulden auf private
Schulden gibt was im wesentlichen eine
Verlagerung des Risikos ist weg von den
Aktiengesellschaften und der Regierung
auf die Schultern von Individuen und es
werden die verwundbarsten Individuen
sein die die meiste Schuld tragen werden
es ist also kein progressiver sondern
ein regressiver politischer Rahmen dem
sich die Praktikum verschrieben hat bei
dem das Risiko auf die am meisten
verwundbaren abgewälzt wird wenn es
einen weiteren finanzschock gibt einen
Ölschock zum Beispiel dann werden die
ärmsten Menschen in der Gesellschaft die
Strafe zahlen oder Hausbesitzer werden
in eine überschuldungssteuern wenn die
Zinsen nur ein oder zwei Prozent steigen
es wird richtig große Probleme geben
deswegen denke ich dass das überhaupt
keinen sinnvoller Weg nach vorne ist es
ist regressiv und sicherlich nicht fair
zu den Bedingungen von denen die
Regierung spricht und es ist mit
Sicherheit auch keinen Fall von das
stehen wir gemeinsam durch
kommt da immer mehr Ressourcen und
Industrien des Landes privatisiert
werden nimmt der private Sektor mehr
Schulden auf dadurch wird mehr Geld
geschaffen und es gibt einen Boom
einige Private Equity-Unternehmen haben
diese Theorie auf die Spitze getrieben
und betreiben eine Praxis die als
leverage bei Art bekannt ist bei der ein
Unternehmen zu einem oft überhöhten
Preis gekauft wird und der Kaufpreis als
Schuld an das Unternehmen übertragen
wird
[Musik]
das Unternehmen wird für die
Finanzierung des eigenen Kaufs
verantwortlich diese Schulden sind oft
so groß dass das Unternehmen
personalgehälter und
Forschungsaktivitäten reduzieren muss
wenn sie Zinsen als Unternehmen
berücksichtigen müssen wenn sie die
zinsrückzahlung in ihre Waren und
Dienstleistungen einbeziehen dann müssen
sie einen dauerhaft höheren Preis
verlangen wenn sie immer mehr Schulden
aufnehmen
eine Zunahme der Diversifizierung der
Schulden führt zu einer Erhöhung der
Geldmenge
wenn die Geldmenge steigt steht mehr
Geld für produktive Aktivitäten und
Konsum zur Verfügung was die
Voraussetzung für einen Boom ist
es ist fraglich ob wir diese Rezession
überwinden oder ob es so bleibt wie es
jetzt ist falls wir jedoch die Rezession
überwinden und die Wirtschaft wieder
wächst beobachtet was mit den Schulden
passiert die Schulden werden ansteigen
und zwar umso schneller je schneller die
Wirtschaft wächst in drei bis fünf
Jahren werden wir wieder dort sein wo
wir einst waren die Schulden werden so
viel und die Leute werden ihre Kredite
wieder nicht bedienen können es liegt an
dem System indem wir zurzeit eingesperrt
sind die Wirtschaft kann nicht wachsen
ohne dass die Schulden ansteigen und es
sind die Schulden die die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen lassen die einzige
Option ist die Banken daran zu hindern
Geld als Schulden zu schaffen indem wir
das Geldsystem ändern können wir die
Banken davon abhalten eine weitere
Finanzkrise zu verursachen außerdem
können wir die Kürzung der
Sozialleistungen die Steuererhöhungen
und den Anstieg der Staatsverschuldung
unnötig machen
das derzeitige System erlaubt es den
Banken Geld aus der Wirtschaft
abzuschöpfen ohne im Gegenzug etwas
Produktives zu leisten
warum ist es so dass wir all die
Technologie haben diese neue Effizienz
und trotzdem braucht es mittlerweile
zwei Personen um einen Haushalt zu
finanzieren während es in den 50er
Jahren nur eine Person brauchte die Geld
verdiente der Grund dafür ist nicht das
Waschmaschinen und alles andere teurer
wird es ist wegen der Schulden und weil
der Bankensektor bei allen anderen
absahnt ein wachsender Bankensektor ist
also nichts Gutes wenn er Bankensektor
wächst liegt es daran dass er entweder
ineffizienter oder ein Parasit für den
Rest der Wirtschaft wird wenn der
Bankensektor 4 5 6 % des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes ausmacht was
passiert mit dem Rest der Wirtschaft der
verringert sich auf 96 95 94% des BIP
wir müssen uns jetzt einmischen wenn wir
irgendeines der anderen großen sozialen
Probleme angehen wollen müssen wir
zuerst das Geld Problem lösen
die
Ärmsten auf dieser Welt Zahlen für
Krisen auch wenn sie nicht von den auf
rücksichtslosen und höchst spekulativen
Booms profitiert haben wie der
immobilienboomen Irland der dieser Krise
vorausgegangen ist in den letzten 30
Jahren haben wir einen Anstieg in den
Einkommensunterschieden gesehen bei dem
die Reichen sehr viel reicher wurden
aber normale Menschen nicht sie
verdienen genauso viel oder sind sogar
ärmer geworden ein Weg die Wirtschaft am
Laufen zu halten war diesen Menschen
günstige Kredite zur Verfügung zu
stellen Ihnen Schulden anzubieten weil
sie sich nichts mehr wirklich leisten
konnten damit sie weiter kaufen wenn es
kollabiert sind es dieselben Menschen
die wieder zahlen müssen auch wenn sie
in vielerlei Hinsicht schon zuvor die
Opfer waren
aufgrund der Krise hat die Zentralbank
von England firmenschulden aufgekauft
und niedriger verzinst dennoch wird von
der durchschnittlichen Person verlangt
mehr denn je zu zahlen um
Überziehungskredite und Kreditkarten zu
erhalten
Schulden zwischen den sehr reichen oder
zwischen Regierungen können immer neu
verhandelt werden und so war es schon
immer in der Weltgeschichte Schulden
sind nicht in Stein gemeißelt es ist im
allgemeinen wenn man Schulden hat die
die Arme den Reichen Schulden dass diese
plötzlich zu einer heiligen
Verpflichtung werden die wichtiger ist
als alles andere die Idee Schulden neu
zu verhandeln wird plötzlich undenkbar
können Sie genau sagen was die
Investoren bei Laune hält und sie
zuversichtlicher machen würde
das ist schwierig zu sagen persönlich
spielt es keine Rolle sehen Sie ich bin
ein Händler mich interessiert so etwas
nicht wirklich
zahle deine Steuern
wenn ich eine Chance sehe Geld zu
verdienen ergreife ich sie die meisten
von uns Händlern interessieren sich
nicht so sehr dafür wie man die
Wirtschaft stabilisieren kann unsere
Aufgabe ist es damit Geld zu verdienen
und ich persönlich träume seit drei
Jahren von diesem Moment wenn Sie wissen
was zu tun ist können Sie damit viel
Geld verdienen ich muss ein Geständnis
ablegen ich gehe jede Nacht ins Bett ich
träume von einer weiteren Rezession ich
träume von einem weiteren Moment wie
diesem damit können Sie viel Geld
verdienen
Bruno Virginia hat jemand im ganz böse
wehgetan
wenn man sich in Europa umschaut und
sieht wie der neue Ministerpräsident von
Griechenland nicht gewählt sondern
eingesetzt wurde Papa Demos ein
ehemaliger Mitarbeiter von Goldman Sachs
der neue Premierminister und
Finanzminister Italiens Mario Monti
ehemaliger Mitarbeiter von Goldman Sachs
der neue Präsident der Europäischen
Zentralbank ehemaliger Mitarbeiter von
Goldman Sex deren Leute sind überall das
ist der Weg um zu verändern was wir
haben alle Macht und alle Freiheiten von
den Menschen wegzunehmen und alles in
die Hände einer kleinen Gruppe mit
absoluter Macht zu geben
vom Volk ohne das Volk gegen das Volk
was bei all dem interessant war ist die
Frage der Demokratie die in Europa sehr
stark aufgeworfen wurde dass man eine
Regierung von Bankern hat die einem im
Wesentlichen aufgezwungen wurde es sind
Banker die uns mehr oder weniger in
diese Lage gebracht haben klingt übel
ist aber wahr und dann sagen sie okay
dieselben Banker sollen uns jetzt retten
und sie werden jetzt ihr Land regieren
das ist eine ernste Frage der Demokratie
die sich hier auftut
übrigens hat die Bankenkrise mehr als
100 Millionen Menschen zurück in die
Armut getrieben
die Sterblichkeitsrate von Menschen die
in die Armut gerutscht sind steigt aus
einer ganzen Reihe von Gründen enorm an
bei der Bankenkrise ging es also nicht
nur darum ärmer zu werden es ging auch
um die Tötung von Menschen und wissen
Sie was ein Ende ist nicht in Sicht wir
haben nie jemanden zur Rechenschaft
gezogen und wir haben nicht die radikale
Reformarbeit geleistet weil wir
fälschlicherweise dachten wenn wir die
Situation weiter die stabilisieren würde
es die Sache noch schlimmer machen und
da hatten sie mal wer die Entscheidungen
getroffen hat all die Leute die vorher
schon da waren
ich denke Sie sollten wissen dass das
Geschäft eines dieser Geschäftsleute
Mord ist
ihre Waffen sind modern doch ihr Denken
2000 Jahre alt
sehen Sie ich war dabei als der Sekretär
und der Vorsitzende der Federer Reserve
in diesen Tagen zusammenkamen und
Mitgliedern des Kongresses darüber
sprachen was vor sich ging es war der 15
September
am Donnerstag gegen 11 Uhr bemerkte die
Federal Reserve einen enormen Rückgang
der Geldmarkt konnten in den Vereinigten
Staaten 550 Milliarden Dollar wurden in
ein oder zwei Stunden herausgezogen
das Finanzministerium Punkte 105
Milliarden Dollar in das System und
erkannte schnell dass diese Menge Geld
nicht helfen wird wir hatten einen
elektronischen Run auf die Banken sie
entschieden den Betrieb so wie die
Geldkonten zu schließen und eine
Garantie von 250.000 Dollar pro Konto
anzukündigen damit es keine weitere
Panik geben wird das ist tatsächlich
passiert
wenn sie das nicht getan hätten wären
wohl bis um 2 Uhr an diesem Nachmittag
5,5 Millionen Dollar aus dem
geldmarktsystem der Vereinigten Staaten
gezogen worden es hätte die gesamte
Wirtschaft der Vereinigten Staaten
zerstört und innerhalb von 24 Stunden
wäre die Weltwirtschaft
zusammengebrochen
internationale Aspekte
wenn Geld international von einer
Währung in einer anderen abgehoben wird
verschiebt sich die Reservewährung von
der Nationalbank eines Landes auf das
reservekonto der ausländischen Bank
ausländische Banken unterhalten
Beziehungen zu lokalen Banken die es
Ihnen ermöglichen devisenwährungen zu
halten ohne Teil des zentralbanksystems
der lokalen Zentralbank zu sein
wenn beispielsweise 1000 Pfund in Euro
überwiesen werden vereinbart eine
britische Bank mit einer Bank des
Euro-Raums einen Wechselkurs die
britische Bank überweist dann 1.000
Pfund der zentralen Reservewährung an
die britische Partnerbank der
europäischen Bank während die
europäische Bank 1.150 Euro
Reservewährung an die europäische
Partnerbank der britischen Bank
überweist
was passiert wenn Währungen und das
Wechselkurssystem nicht mehr verwaltet
werden was sind einige der ersten
Konsequenzen Abwertungen Spekulation
Ungleichgewichte wo einige Länder immer
mehr und mehr von Wasser sammeln würden
andere Währungen
muss im Ursprungsland ausgegeben und in
andere Währungen umgetauscht werden
die meisten ausländischen Banken
verfügen nicht über Einlagen konnten
außerhalb ihrer Landesgrenzen und daher
kommen die von ihnen gehaltenen
Währungsreserven nicht in Form von
Einlagen an Sie zurück
wenn ein Land Handels Ungleichgewichte
anhäuft akumuliert es entweder die
wiesenreservewährungen im Falle von
Überschüssen oder gibt seine eigenen
Reserven im Falle negativer
Handelsbilanzen aus
die Handelsbilanz ist im Grunde der
Unterschied zwischen dem was sie im
Ausland verkaufen und dem was sie aus
dem Ausland kaufen nun das Merkmal des
Vereinigten Königreichs ist dass es für
einen sehr langen Zeitraum ein Defizit
von etwas hatte dass als sichtbare
Handelsbilanz bezeichnet wird die Dinge
handelt die Sie sehen können das sind
also Waren die man erkennen würde Dinge
die man in Container stecken kann es
sind Autos Computer Dinge die man in
einem Geschäft sehen würde das war
erhebliches Defizit ich denke es öffnet
sich in den frühen 1980er Jahren und im
Wesentlichen ist es seitdem nicht
verschwunden wenn überhaupt ist es
größer und größer geworden
Reserven können nicht direkt für
inländische Ausgaben verwendet werden
das Geld kann nur im Ausland oder für
Importe ausgegeben werden ein Land mit
einem großen Handelsbilanzdefizit ist
darauf angewiesen dass seine Gläubiger
die auf ihrem eigenen Markt
aufgelaufenen Ungleichgewichte ausgeben
in der Vergangenheit gab es Vorschläge
einen Mechanismus zu schaffen mit dem
diese Ungleichgewichte ausgeglichen
werden können zum Beispiel John Maynard
Kains am Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
sein ursprünglicher Vorschlag für das
was bradon Woods und die dort
angesiedelten Institutionen wie der IWF
und die Weltbank wurden war dass es eine
Art internationale clearing Union geben
würde diese bezog sich insbesondere auf
die handelsseite und nicht direkt auf
die finanzielle Seite aber das Prinzip
war das sobald sie die Handelsbilanzen
geöffnet hätten jeder über eine
internationale clearing Bank spielen
würde und das würde jeden zwingen die
Ungleichgewichte die in der
Realwirtschaft auftraten schließlich ins
Gleichgewicht zu bringen aber so einen
Mechanismus gibt es nicht das kumulierte
netto-handels Ungleichgewicht des
Vereinigten Königreichs beträgt rund 800
Milliarden
währungskriege
im Wesentlichen ist es so dass einige
Länder über viele Jahre hinweg große
Handelsüberschüsse und andere große
Handelsdefizite hatten die Länder mit
handelsdefiziten haben mehr ausgegeben
als sie verdient haben also mussten sie
Kredite aus dem Ausland aufnehmen und
das haben sie Jahr für Jahr getan Länder
wie dieses die Vereinigten Staaten wir
selbst und einige andere Länder in
Europa das kann so nicht weitergehen und
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten wie das zu
einem Ende kommen kann eine Möglichkeit
wäre und wir haben das in einigen
Ländern in Europa gesehen wenn sie keine
neuen Wege finden um wettbewerbsfähig zu
werden dann wird ihre Fähigkeit die
Schulden zurückzuzahlen in Frage
gestellt eine andere Möglichkeit das zu
tun ist dass wir einen glaubwürdigen
Plan Zurückzahlung unserer Schulden
haben und der Wert des Pfund Sterling um
25% gefallen ist um unsere Exporte für
ausländische Käufer wettbewerbsfähiger
und begehrenswerter zu machen und es für
britische Verbraucher attraktiver zu
machen von britischen Produzenten zu
kaufen anstatt von ausländischen
Produzenten
ist es was wir getan haben um einen
Rahmen zu schaffen unsere Wirtschaft
wieder ins Gleichgewicht zu bringen
Währungskrieg auch bekannt als
kompetitive Abwertung ist eine Bedingung
in der Länder gegeneinander konkurrieren
um einen relativ niedrigen Wechselkurs
für ihre Währung zu erreichen wenn der
Preis für den Kauf einer bestimmten
Währung fällt sinkt auch der reale Preis
der exporter aus diesem Land die
heimische Industrie erhält sowohl im in
als auch im Ausland eine Nachfrageschub
es hat die britischen Exporte ziemlich
billig erscheinen lassen so dass sie
sich ein wenig erholt haben aber
irgendwann fielen sie wieder was wir
also sehen ist eine Art Anarchie und in
gewisser Weise eine zunehmende Anarchie
das ist es was in den letzten Jahren
passiert ist worüber der brasilianische
Finanzminister am lautesten gesprochen
hat Gespräche über währungskriege und
über den Wunsch der nationalen
Regierungen wenn sie mit einer großen
Rezession konfrontiert sind denken Sie
wenn wir mehr exportieren könnten
könnten wir uns aus dieser Rezession
befreien wenn wir mehr exportieren
wollen werden wir unsere Währung ab das
macht unsere wahren billiger alle
anderen kaufen Sie und wir werden alle
besser dran sein das Problem hier ist
wenn sie abwerten ist es als ob alle
anderen gegen sie abwerten deren Sachen
werden teurer also sind sie nicht
glücklich darüber sie wollen dann auch
entwerten und hier entwickelt sich eine
abwertungsspirale
zu verringern verkauft eine nationale
Zentralbank Reservewährung auf dem Markt
es erzeugt diese Währung aus dem Nichts
in dem es Zahlen in einen Computer
eingibt das heißt eine Zentralbank
kaufte Wiesen
der Betrag den eine Zentralbank schaffen
kann ist nicht begrenzt weil es keine
definierten Werte hinter der
Reservewährung gibt
während der langen Phase des warengeldes
wurde der Wechselkurs durch die Menge an
Gold Silber und Kupfer in den Münzen der
einzelnen Länder bestimmt auch nach der
Einführung von Papiergeld und dem
Goldstandard war der Wechselkurs
abhängig von der versprochenen Menge an
Gold die die Regierung einen Besitzer
einer Banknote zahlen würde diese
Beträge schwanken kurzfristig kaum und
Wechselkurse zwischen Währungen waren
relativ stabil
ity nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg waren
Währungen an den Dollar gekoppelt und
der Dollar war durch Gold gedeckt dieses
System endete 1971
wir haben ein modernes Finanzsystem in
dem Geld chaotisch organisiert ist es
gibt keinen Wechselkurs da es keinen
Goldstandard zu erhalten gilt wir
brauchen also keinen wir glauben dass
der Markt alle Probleme des Tausches
lösen wird ob ihre Währung mehr wert
sein sollte als meine ist eine
Spiegelung der Stärke ihrer Wirtschaft
im Vergleich zu meiner sollte sich das
Verhältnis ändern kann sich der Index
für währungswechselkurse ändern es
geschieht auf magische Weise durch die
Effizienz des Marktes und Profitstreben
ihr kennt den Rest denke ich
[Musik]
eine Währung in Bezug auf eine andere
Währung wird durch den Markt bestimmt
wenn mehr Leute eine Währung kaufen als
verkaufen wollen dann steigt ihr Wert
wenn mehr Leute verkaufen wollen dann
singt ihr Wert der Wert wird von
einzelnen Banken festgelegt die
Währungen kaufen und verkaufen sie
passen den Wechselkurs an
die letzte Studie die ich 2007 jeden Tag
über die Devisenmärkte gelesen habe
zeigt es werden jeden Tag 3,2 Millionen
Dollar gehandelt wer weiß was das
globale BIP ist
50 Billionen Dollar 50 noch mal höher 60
60 das ist näher dran
überlegen Sie das diese Menge jeden Tag
gehandelt wird es gibt ungefähr 260
Werktage im Jahr es dauert ein paar
Wochen um dem globalen Wert jeder
wirtschaftlichen Leistung die überall
jeden Tag ein Jahr lang erbracht wird
gleich zu kommen
es dauert ein paar Wochen
ein jeder von uns handelt offensichtlich
ziemlich regelmäßig mit Währungen wenn
Sie verreisen tauschen Sie sie in eine
andere Währung um das ist eine Art von
Währungshandel sie tauschen ihre Pfund
in Euros Yen oder was auch immer es sein
mag das passiert ziemlich häufig und das
ist ein konventioneller Teil des
handelsprozesses große Unternehmen
müssen regelmäßig umtauschen was
Menschen allerdings in Frage stellen
wenn sie sagen Moment das ist
Spekulation nämlich wenn Sie realisieren
dass Währungen sich nebeneinander
bewegen und wenn sie sich im Wert
nebeneinander bewegen dann gibt es immer
eine Chance zu versuchen Geld aus der
Veränderung des Wertes zu machen das ist
der Teil des Marktes den eine
Finanztransaktionssteuer versuchen würde
einzudämmen weil die nicht gänzlich
falsche Annahme ist dass es nur
Instabilität für alle anderen verursacht
diese Menschen wollen Volatilität im
Markt denn so verdienen sie ihr Geld sie
wollen sie verstärken und verstärken sie
indem sie so handeln und spekulieren wie
sie es tun
bis zum Jahr 2010 war der Devisenmarkt
zum größten und flüssigsten der Welt
angewachsen durchschnittlich 4 Billionen
Dollar an Währungen wurden jeden Tag
gehandelt
verursacht not was macht es mit Ländern
vielleicht besonders kleinen
Entwicklungsländern wenn auf einmal
riesige und ständig schwankender
Finanzströme kommen
was können die tun um damit umzugehen
die Produktion erhöhen und mehr
verkaufen die Preise senken und
möglicherweise noch ärmer werden
wenn man anfängt über das internationale
System zu reden wird es schnell
eigenartig viel davon hängt von
Empfindungen und Meinungen darüber ab
wie es um eine Wirtschaft steht mehr als
es davon abhängt was eine Wirtschaft
tatsächlich tut oder nicht tut das kann
sich sehr schnell verschieben denn wenn
es nur um jemandes Meinung geht ob eine
Währung tragbar ist dann kann man das
glauben solange man will wenn sich diese
Meinung ändert und an den Finanzmärkten
kann sie sich sehr schnell ändern kann
es innerhalb von Minuten sogar Sekunden
zu dem Prozess der finanziellen
Ansteckung kommen so können Sie von
einer scheinbar stabilen robusten
Wirtschaft zu einer werden gegen die
sich plötzlich die Stimmung wendet und
auf einmal merken sie dass die Märkte es
auf sie abgesehen haben oft braucht es
nicht mehr als dass sie der Nachbar
eines Landes sind das sind
Schwierigkeiten ist
viele der weltweiten Finanzkrisen der
letzten 30 Jahre wurden durch den
hastigen Abzug der Währung eines Landes
oder einer ganzen Region verursacht
diese Art von Aktivität wird oft als
finanzielle Kriegsführung bezeichnet
davon haben bedeutende Institutionen
erheblich profitiert wie Goldman Sex zum
Beispiel jeder größeren Bank ging es
aufgrund dieser Art von Regelungen
besser als es in einem regulierteren
Umfeld der Fall gewesen wäre es hat
bestimmt Leute sehr sehr reich gemacht
es hat den Finanzmärkten eine enorme
Expansion ermöglicht jeder daran
beteiligte ist scharf auf eine
deregulierte Welt im Falle von England
haben sie eine Regierung die ziemlich
offen vorsätzlich und aggressiv gegen
jegliche Form der Regulierung der
Finanzmärkte argumentiert hat aber es
ist nicht der Fall dass jemand hinter
den Kulissen die Fäden sieht so laufen
die Dinge ab ihr wollt und offen direkt
vor Ihren Augen so ist die Welt nunmal
manche Menschen macht das sehr reich und
die sind recht zufrieden damit
ich denke es ist eine Art von
wirtschaftlicher Kriegsführung ein
Großteil der Veränderung der letzten 30
Jahre in der Art wie die Weltwirtschaft
funktioniert resultiert aus den Schulden
der Entwicklungsländer weil es den
reichen Ländern den Banken und dem
Finanzsektor enorme Macht und Kontrolle
über die ärmeren Regionen der Welt
gegeben hat in denen es eine große Menge
an Ressourcen gibt die wir gerne
verbrauchen
das ganze in einer Weise die viele Leute
mit einer Form des Kolonialismus
vergleichen es ist eine sehr direkte Art
von macht um diese Länder zu Dingen zu
zwingen die im Interesse der reichsten
Länder der Welt sind
kooperations bekommen absolutel in very
Youtube Folge dessen sind nicht nur die
Konzerne unglaublich profitabel groß
mächtig und alles durchdringend geworden
sondern die Finanzbranche ist sogar noch
größer geworden richtig Geld verdienen
tut man heute nicht indem man etwas
herstellt sondern einfach durch
bestimmte Formen der Spekulation Geld
aus Geld machen das ist die
profitabelste und bei weitem größte
wirtschaftliche Aktivität die es heute
auf der Welt gibt
activity
um sich zu schützen müssen sich
gefährdete Länder mit Währungen der
reichen Länder eindecken diese stellen
die Währungen aus dem Nichts her
die Niederlande der erste general
Gouverneur von Indonesien der Mann der
die Handelswege aufgebaut hat ließ ihnen
entlang Festungen errichten und
bekämpfte spanische und britische
flotten
bezüglich des niederländischen Imperiums
und Handels sagte er wir können keinen
Handel betreiben ohne Krieg und keinen
Krieg führen ohne Handel
finanzieller Imperialismus
Reserven sind zu einer Art Versicherung
geworden wogegen Spekulation sie hatten
Spekulation gesagt einen spekulativen
Angriff fallende Märkte blasen
wenn ein Land einem Angriff der
Spekulation er liegt dann wird eine
Deregulierung seiner Märkte verlangt um
sein Finanzsystem dem der dominierenden
Partei anzupassen
the big problem this den meisten
Entwicklungsländern die in eine
Finanzkrise geraten sind wird von den
höheren Mächten der Welt dem IWF der ein
vielerlei Hinsicht das globale
Finanzsystem regiert gesagt dass der Weg
aus den Schulden eine Restrukturierung
der Wirtschaft sei besonders die Exporte
zu erhöhen um mehr Dollar zu verdienen
dann können Sie Ihre Schulden in Dollar
oder einer anderen fremden Währung
zurückzahlen leider wurde immer und
immer wieder bewiesen dass das ganz und
gar nicht der Fall ist diese Länder
haben ihre öffentlichen Ausgaben auf ein
Minimum reduziert das Wachstum und das
Wachstumspotenzial kamen zum Stillstand
und was sie herstellten war für die
Exportmärkte bestimmt um ein Dollar zu
kommen sie haben ihre Schulden abbezahlt
haben aber ihre eigene Wirtschaft nicht
entwickelt die Schulden Tilgung betrug
weit mehr als sie für Gesundheit Bildung
oder sonst etwas Ausgaben und ihre
Schulden wuchsen und wuchsen weiter
weiter
das Land wird zu einem basalenstaat der
es den großen Konzernen ermöglicht die
natürlichen Ressourcen und die
Arbeitskräfte auszubeuten finanzieller
Imperialismus ausbauen Pflege der
kolonialen macht durch finanzielle
Dominanz
was hier passiert und wie die Welt läuft
es ist ziemlich unverblümt seit den
letzten 30 Jahren breitet sich überall
etwas aus was meistens Neoliberalismus
genannt wird eine Idee von flexiblen
Wechselkursen schwache Regulierung
besonders der Finanzmärkte minimale
staatliche Einmischung in die Märkte und
so funktioniert die Welt mehr oder
weniger und dann gibt es diese
Institutionen eine bedeutsame derzeit
ist der IWF die versuchen diese
Situation zu erzwingen das ist also
nicht sonderlich obskura als ob Menschen
im Hintergrund die Fäden ziehen sondern
es ist ziemlich offensichtlich es
passiert und zwar so schon seit ich
erwachsen bin wie es aussieht ist das
wie die Welt funktioniert und es hat
einige Menschen sehr reich gemacht es
hat enorme Konzentrat Rahmen von
Vermögen verursacht
kann sehen inute to try and
Elli V8 der wenn der Internationale
Währungsfonds eingreift um die Schulden
eines Landes in den Griff zu bekommen
dann sind daran Konditionen geknüpft in
den 1980er und 90er Jahren haben sie es
strukturelles Anpassungsprogramm genannt
es neigt dazu ähnliche Formen anzunehmen
egal wo es passiert wir können
strukturelle Anpassungsprogramme heute
in Griechenland Portugal und Irland
beobachten Länder werden angehalten die
öffentlichen Ausgaben zu senken sie
werden angewiesen ihre Handels und
Kapitalmärkte zu liberalisieren Geld
kann so sehr viel leichter ihn und aus
der Wirtschaft strömen das soll
Investitionen aus reicheren Teilen der
Welt anlocken und all ihre Probleme
lösen in Wirklichkeit hat sich immer
wieder herausgestellt dass das
vollkommen unbegründet ist
[Musik]
tatsächlich hat es aufkommende Industrie
und Kapazitäten in diesen
Entwicklungsländern zerstört die
Entwicklungsländer wurden komplett von
Gütern und Dienstleistungen entwickelter
Länder abhängig und auch von deren
Kapital eine Sache auf die der IWF
besonders besteht ist die Senkung der
Steuern die multinationale Konzerne
bezahlen müssen wenn sie dort ihren
Betrieb aufnehmen denn so locken sie
mehr multinationale Konzerne an
natürlich bedeutet das auch dass die
Gewinne der Konzerne das Land ebenso
schnell verlassen das Land selbst
profitiert davon nicht heute haben sie
viele Entwicklungsländer die fast kein
Steuer aufkommen haben sie sind also
noch abhängiger von den internationalen
Finanzmärkten den Geldmärkten vom
Schulden machen deshalb gibt es so viele
Länder auf der Welt die ihrer
Souveränität beraubt wurden wie soll
sich eine demokratische Gesellschaft
entwickeln oder funktionieren wenn eine
Regierung abhängiger vom IWF und den
Geld merkten ist als von ihrem eigenen
Erfolg
Finanzinstrumente
was wir seit den 1970er Jahren sehen ist
eine dramatische Zunahme eine Reihe von
Phänomenen die eine stimulierende
Wirkung auf die Veränderungen im
Finanzsystem hatten die uns zu dem
glänzenden Metall und Stahlgeschäft
gebracht haben dass da drüben ist falls
Sie nicht wissen was ich zeige auf die
City of London
um das viele in eines definierten
rohstoff-basierten Wertes zu
kompensieren der Währungen zugrunde
liegt entwickelten Finanzinstitute für
briefungen als Mittel zur
Risikosteuerung sie entwickeln
fabriefungen als Mittel um zu versuchen
das gesamte System zu stabilisieren das
ist eine Reihe von finanzprozessen und
Finanzinnovationen die sich seit den
70er und 80er Jahren wirklich
beschleunigen
sie hatten einen chaotisches System das
Risiken managen und innovativ sein
musste man brauchte Derivate Optionen
Futures sie haben neue Märkte für
volatilitätsmanagement Tools wer weiß
was der Begriff hatching ist das Risiko
streuen managen Sie Ihr Risiko
versichern Sie sich dagegen genau bis in
die 1960er Jahre hinein äußerte sich die
Securities and Exchange Commission ganz
deutlich dass Derivate die nicht auf
echten Produkten wie solchen aus der
Landwirtschaft also Schweinebauch
Futures oder etwas ähnlichem basieren
Glücksspiel wären und somit der Handel
mit solchen Derivaten untersagt ist das
veränderte sich in den 1960er Jahren
jeder konnte mit währungsfutures Handeln
Dinge die nicht auf handfesten Produkten
basieren die zu einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt in der Zukunft gehandelt
werden sondern auf Schwankungen von
währungspreisen als das System der fixen
Wechselkurse zusammenbricht beschleunigt
sich diese Sachen natürlich enorm wo
staatliche Regulierungen abgebaut werden
stimmt der Markt mit seinen eigenen
Produkten die Theorie besagt dass der
Markt sich besser selbst reguliert die
Hypothese von den effizienten Märkten
ist die Idee dass man einen
finanzmarktaufbaut der schnell ist alle
sind gut informiert alle beobachten ganz
genau was jeder andere tut daher wird er
sehr stabil sein und der Spiegel
tatsächlicher Veränderungen in der
Wirtschaft wieder er wird nicht von
Paniken Manien und Spekulationsblasen
angetrieben wenn es auf und
Abwärtsbewegungen gibt dann nur weil
tatsächlich etwas passiert worauf
Händler und Investoren in den
Finanzmärkten lediglich reagieren das
ist die Hypothese von den effizienten
Märkten und ich glaube 2008 ist auf eine
Art das Ende dieses Prozesses das
Auftreten einer so gewaltigen Krise dass
der Glaube sie sei selbst stabilisierend
und regulierend nicht aufrechterhalten
werden kann die Methode wird sowieso
weiter angewendet aber man kann nicht
mehr wie zuvor argumentieren sie sei gut
oder notwendig oder sie sei okay für die
Welt
in den letzten zehn Jahren hatten wir
eine weitere Innovation etwas das als
credit default Swap bezeichnet wird eine
Möglichkeit eine Versicherung gegen ein
Unternehmen zu kaufen in das sie
investiert haben um Pleite zu gehen im
Jahr 2002 betrogen sie weniger als eine
Billion Dollar im Jahr 2007 waren es 60
Billionen Dollar dazwischen liegen 5
Jahre
da und sagen oh dieses CDOs die wir
gemacht haben bieten tatsächlich nicht
die Art von Stabilität die wir dachten
die Mathematik die in ihnen steckt ist
völliger Unsinn wie sich herausstellt
der Versuch Risiken und Schulden so zu
verbriefen wie wir es getan haben ist
mit weitaus größeren Risiken verbunden
als wir dachten und wir denken jetzt
dass diese Dinge wertlos sind
der Versuch immer komplexere Wege zur
Regulierung und Gestaltung eines
Finanzmarktes zu finden und zu versuchen
auch schnelles Geld daraus zu machen
Druck tatsächlich dazu bei den
gegenteiligen Effekt zu dem zu erzielen
was seine Befürworter sagten nämlich
dass es zu einem spektakulären Crash
führte
was wir als Ergebnis dieser sehr anderen
Situation gesehen haben war vor allem
ein Phänomen ein Sektor ist vor allem
gewachsen und das war der Finanzsektor
während der Finanzsektor enorm vom
gegenwärtigen Währungssystem profitiert
ist das System weder stabil noch fair
die Annahme bei dem was die Bank auf
England im Moment tut ist dass das
Bargeld das wir haben durch die
Staatsschulden gedeckt ist die Regierung
kann ihr Versprechen dadurch bekräftigen
dass es Steuern erheben kann was sie
damit andeuten ist dass das Bargeld
durch Staatsschulden gedeckt ist während
Staatsschulden durch die Fähigkeit der
Regierung Bargeld von den Steuerzahlern
zu kriegen gedeckt sind
in den letzten 30 Jahren wurden private
Schulden immer wieder in Staatsschulden
verwandelt letztlich wird der Preis für
die Schulden von der Öffentlichkeit im
Schuldner Land bezahlt
deshalb sind Ausgaben Kürzungen
notwendig das System soll bestimmte
Menschen auf Kosten der Bürger und
Steuerzahler einer Nation sehr reich
machen das System senkt den
Lebensstandard der Mehrheit und verteilt
diesen Reichtum unter den privilegierten
Jahren ein Finanzsystem ohne fixe
Wechselkurse das plötzlich zunehmend
offene Grenzen für Kapital hat
das Zentralbanken hat die ohne Kontrolle
verwalten müssen dann nichts ist wo
früher das Gold war
die chaotisch expansive Geldpolitik
betreiben müssen die als Kreditgeber
letzter Instanz einspringen müssen
im Laufe der Geschichte wurden
Geldsysteme entworfen um der dominanten
internationalen macht einen Vorteil zu
verschaffen und diese Macht wird heftig
verteidigt und erweitert
internationale Währungsreform
sehen würde ist eine neue Art der
Währung die durch etwas gestützt wird
das selten ist und dass wir wirklich
brauchen und wir wirklich schätzen so
etwas wie Energie oder erneuerbare
Energie zum Beispiel eine auf
Kilowattstunden basierte Währung wäre
sehr interessant für mich wir müssen
anfangen die Dinge zu schätzen die am
seltensten sind und dass wir als
menschliche Spezies auf lange Sicht
überleben müssen eine internationale
Währung auf so etwas zu stützen wird
enorme Investitionen in z.B erneuerbare
Energien zur Folge haben wenn das die
Premiere international gebrauchte
Berechnungseinheit wird eine weitere
Option ist ein Kopf von Währungen bei
dem der Wert verschiedener Währungen
vermischt wird um eine sehr solide
Währung zu schaffen in die die Menschen
Vertrauen haben
vielleicht wäre ein Kopf von Rohstoffen
mit dem internationale Währungen
gesichert werden können noch besser
wenn es irgendwie international möglich
wäre die zunehmend konkurrierende
nationalen Volkswirtschaften
zusammenzubringen um eine Vereinbarung
ähnlich der von Brad zu schreiben die im
Gegensatz zu Bretten Woods erlaubt
einige Währungen an verschiedene Körbe
von Gütern zu binden die zu ihren
nationalen Volkswirtschaften passen denn
man das Arrangieren könnte wäre das fein
man könnte beobachten wie das eine Art
Ordnung in die internationale
Makroökonomie bringen würde die ihr
ansonsten fehlt die wirkliche
Schwierigkeit dabei ist politisch wer
auf der Welt macht es wer ist die
Kaufkraft die das Geschehen macht
die Schaffung eines Geldsystems das
sowohl fair als auch stabil ist ist
möglich und kann erreicht werden wozu
dienen internationale Organisationen
wenn nicht für einen solchen Zweck
woher kommt das Geld ein Teil des
Voiceovers für diesen Dokumentarfilm
stammt aus diesem Buch
[Musik]
George George arbeitete in einer großen
Bank in der City of London one day aber
eines Tages ging Georges Bank ohne
Vorwarnung Pleite
glücklicherweise rettete die Regierung
die Bank und George behielt seinen Job
aber die gierige Regierung wollte etwas
als Gegenleistung für ihre Hilfe sie
forderte eine höhere Steuer auf Georges
Gehalt und Boni für jemanden mit einem
kostspieligen Lebensstil wie George kann
ein Schock wie dieser verheerend sein
jetzt kämpft George darum sich die Miete
für seine Wohnung am Flussufer im
Zentrum von London zu leisten die Reifen
seines ersten Marten sind abgefahren und
kaum straßentauglich es sei denn Georges
Situation verbessert sich oder jemand
wie sie hilft ihm denn george ist
vielleicht sogar gezwungen an den
Severus schneidern vorbeizugehen und
seinen Anzug bei Topshop oder next zu
kaufen
[Musik]
hätte kann er sich den Champagner zum
Feiern nicht mehr leisten
george ist nicht allein
unzählige andere leiden wie er niemand
weiß wie lange es dauern wird bis die
guten Zeiten wiederkehren
[Musik]
aber mit ihrer Hilfe kann George sein
Leben umkrempeln
eine kleine monatliche Spende von ihnen
kann ein bisschen Sonnenschein
nur 395 Pfund könnten ihm helfen
kleinere Erfolge mit einer Magnumflasche
Champagner zu feiern bereits 900 Pfund
würden George helfen eine neuen Satz
Reifen für seinen ersten Marten zu
kaufen 2000 Pfund können George helfen
sein Selbstwertgefühl mit einem Anzug
von einem renommierten sevel
rosschneider wieder zu erlangen aber
auch ein kleinerer Betrag kann helfen
dafür nur 200 Pfund kann George eine
Mahlzeit für sich und seine Freundin
kaufen
nur 200 extra für die Getränke
wenn Sie eine Patenschaft für einen
Banker übernehmen unterstützen Sie nicht
nur jemanden wie George in einer Zeit
der Not sie unterstützen auch die
trendigen Weinbars der City of London
die luxusautohersteller Italiens und die
Schneider von severo sie würden ihre
patriotische Pflicht tun Großbritanniens
größte Industrie in ihrer Zeit der Not
zu unterstützen und wenn die guten
Zeiten wiederkehren und George seinen
Bonus zurückbekommt werden die Steuern
die Erdzeit dazu beitragen die
öffentlichen Dienstleistungen zu
finanzieren von denen der Rest von euch
schnörern abhängt also bitte bis die
guten Zeiten für George und
seinesgleichen zurückkehren während sie
bereit etwas zu spenden
[Musik]